Film Courage: Markus I was going through
the AFM Twitter and I just found this article
entitled “Thirteen Frequently Used Phrases
That Make You Sound Like a Hollywood Rookie”
by Stephanie Palmer.
And it’s a funny article, there are some
really interesting things in here that I actually
would not have known that if said, would make
someone sound like a rookie, so….13 Phrases
to Avoid (she writes): 1.
High Concept…and I’m just wondering what
your thoughts are because I know you’ll
have something interesting to say.
She says that if your idea is High Concept
it’s obvious.
Saying it won’t help.
2.
We’ve had a lot of interest…Which means
lots of people have read it, but none of them
have liked it to get involved.
3.
With the right cast….Everyone knows this,
basically.
4.
This is a very unique project…which means
it’s a red flag.
If it’s unique you haven’t recent to understand
the genre.
5.
There is another point that Film Courage likes
from this article “It’s with a message.”
Meaning when you’re highlighting that it’s
with a message, this means you’re focusing
primarily on teaching the audience a lesson
instead of telling a great story.
One last one….6.
I’ve been working on this film for 11 years.
She says you’re committed, o.k., possibly
inept.
We’re having fun with this article, but
how much truth do you hear on what the writer
is saying?
Markus Redmond: I think…(pauses).
God bless everybody.
These articles, I take them all with a grain
of salt because there is no road.
I mean to say that these things are going
to make you look like…is to indicate that
these are the things you do correctly and
if you do these things correctly, things will
go the right way.
And there is no “correct.”
The only “correct” is someone writing
you a check.
You can say this is a really unique story
and someone can say ‘I agree with you’
and then they write you a check.
Which makes that completely null and void.
You can say, ‘We’ve had a lot of interest’
and someone can say “Well, let me look at
it, I’m interested.”
And then they write a check, which makes that
saying null and void.
You can’t say the right thing to the wrong
person.
I think that is the real, only thing.
You can’t say the right thing to the wrong
person and you can’t say the wrong thing
to the right person.
I think that means that if it’s not going
to work for somebody, you can’t make it
work for somebody, you know?
I don’t think how you say something if it’s
coming from a place of truth in you, is going
to make the difference.
Like if you’ve got an incredible script
and you’ve got like a really good set of
whatever you’re supposed to have behind
it but you use one of these phrases, someone
who really is in love with your project isn’t
going to say ‘God, I love this script and
he’s got so much great energy and I really
want to work with this person but he used
a rookie term….hhmmm.
Nah…
I better not because he used a rookie term.”
Nobody is going to do that, you know what
I mean?
You either find the people who are your tribe.
You find the people who dig what it is that
you’re looking to do or you don’t.
And in that point, you either decide, I’m
just going to keep looking or you throw in
the towel.
But I don’t think it comes down to say this
or that, or I don’t know.
Maybe it does.
I just think that if you’re coming from
a real place and you’re putting your best
work out there, you just got to keep pushing
until you find the right person.
You know…?
Question For the Viewers: Is there a rookie
mistake that cost you advancement in your
career?